Tonight is supper club.
So basically, what that means is every few weeks,
we invite some friends and family over, and we have a meal together.
And we make a meal with food that we either raised
or we buy it from a farm that we know and trust.
And so everything that is made really has a lot of
love poured into,
and you can really feel that.
I remember sitting in my interview and Miss American,
and I was being asked by the judges,
you know, what's your platform?
Know your food,
know your farmer.
And I. I told them,
I said, there's something so satisfying when you sit down to a meal
and you know how it got there.
You know how these animals were raised.
You know what time it took to grow these vegetables
because you helped grow them.
Think there's something so satisfying,
so beautiful about that, though.
Supper club is a way where you can gather with friends and just, um,
feel that together.
It's such, uh.
It's such a beautiful thing.
And I always feel so grateful for, um,
the meal, and I love teaching my kids that as well.
So something that we have implemented in our lives,
and it's definitely highlight of the week.
Our friends are also band players,
so they always in the night with music.
I'm gonna take you to the.
For these days.
Hey. Oh, wow.